drei tage lang wird ja die der bundestag
hier über die politik der ampel
koalition beraten das alles nennt sich
eine verbundene debatte zu verschiedenen
bereichen also insofern sind es
eigentlich gar keine ist ganz formal
keine ganz getrennten
tagesordnungspunkte deswegen geht es
jetzt sozusagen fast nahtlos vom bereich
innen zum ressort justiz hier sehen sie
schon den zuständen minister marco
buschmann der jetzt hier als nächstes
das wort ergreifen wird das sind ja
immer kleine regierungserklärung in
dieser woche zu jedem ressort und ihnen
zu recht es ist eine fließende
überleitung denn einiges natürlich in
diesen ressorts
überschneidet sich jetzt hören wir
erstmal dem bundesminister der justiz
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen
einigkeit und recht und freiheit so
heißt es im lied der deutschen unsere
hymne besingt wie eng freiheit und recht
miteinander verwoben sind und deshalb
sage ich an dieser stelle ganz klar das
bundesministerium der justiz wird immer
das ministerium des rechtsstaats sein
und es wird immer das ministerium der
freiheit sein
ich sage das in einer zeit des zweifels
eines zweifels auch am wert der freiheit
die ein sorgen sich ob wir je unsere
alte freiheit ohne all die
beschränkungen die in der pandemie
leider notwendig sind wieder vollständig
zurückerhalten und andere wiederum
zweifeln an der freiheit weil die meinen
dass die freiheit des einzelnen
dem gesellschaftlichen fortschritt im
wege stehe in der pandemie beim
klimaschutz sie wünschen sich eine neue
normalität mit weniger freiheit meine
antwort auf diese zweifel lautet es darf
keine neue normalität ohne freiheit
geben wenn es beschränkungen gibt die
heute nötig aber morgen unbegründet sind
dann müssen sie in zukunft fallen meine
damen und herren das versprechen möchte
ich hier abgeben die freiheit des
einzelnen steht auch nicht im
widerspruch zum gesellschaftlichen
fortschritt sondern sie macht sie oft
erst möglich die pandemie hat es doch
gezeigt die besten impfstoffe der welt
sind unter bedingungen der freiheit von
forschung wissenschaft und
unternehmertum hervorgegangen freiheit
und fortschritt gehören untrennbar
zusammen hat damit
seit ist aber nicht anarchie das
zusammenleben von menschen braucht
regeln und freiheitlich sind diese
regeln dann wenn sie die
herausforderungen des miteinanders lösen
und dem einzelnen menschen die räume der
privatheit und auch der selbstentfaltung
lassen freiheit ist nicht abwesenheit
von recht das recht eröffnet oft
überhaupt erst möglichkeiten zur
freiheit und dafür muss es durchgesetzt
werden und deshalb möchte ich mich an
dieser stelle nicht nur bei den vielen
beamtinnen und beamten auf den straßen
bedanken die das gewährleisten sondern
auch bei den richterinnen und richtern
die in den letzten wochen
manch komische häme über sich haben
ergehen lassen müssen wir danken ihnen
für einen wertvollen dienst
das sind die prinzipien
die die rechtspolitik der neuen
bundesregierung leiten werden wer was
das konkret bedeutet kann ich ein
angesichts seiner kurzen rede zeit
natürlich nur kurz an skizzieren sie
möchte ein paar beispiele herausgreifen
wir werden die bürgerrechte stärken und
so für eine neue balance von sicherheit
und freiheit sorgen das gilt
beispielhaft für die
vorratsdatenspeicherung einen
millionenfachen eingriff in die
informationelle selbstbestimmung wir
haben hier heute eine absurde situation
die fortan speicherung steht formal im
gesetz gerichte haben sie aber gestoppt
daher findet sie kaum anwendungen weil
die bundesnetzagentur sie nicht
durchsetzt die vorzeichen und strickt
vorratsdatenspeicherung trägt also kaum
etwas zur sicherheit bei und diese
absurde situation werden wir politisch
beenden die vorratsdatenspeicherung wird
gestrichen stattdessen geben wir den
ermittlungsbehörden das instrument quick
freeze in die hand das heißt wenn es
einen anlass gibt also einen verdacht
eines schweren verbrechens dann ordnet
ein richter die speicherung von
telekommunikationsdaten an ermittler
können sie dann auswerten das ist
rechtsstaatlich sauber und grundrechts
schont das bedeutet fortschritt für
freiheit und sicherheit zugleich meine
damen
ein weiteres feld der sich benennen
möchte ist die gesellschaftspolitik da
kann ich an kollegen hartmann von freien
anknüpfen wir leben in einer
gesellschaft die älter ist wir leben in
einer gesellschaft die mobiler ist
eltern und erwachsene kinder leben
häufig weit voneinander entfernt in
dieser situation stehen sich menschen
auch außerhalb klassischer
familienbeziehungen bei älteren menschen
bilden wohngemeinschaften weil sie nicht
ins heim wollen alleinerziehende helfen
sich bei der kindererziehung weil sie
berufstätig bleiben wollen und diese
menschen leben
verantwortung füreinander
sie wollen aber nicht tisch und bett
teilen sondern vielleicht nur den tisch
sie wollen eine andere art der wahl
verwandtschaft als die ehe oder die
adoption und deshalb werden wir diesen
menschen mit dem neuen institut der
verantwortung gemeinschaft ein stück
rechtliche sicherheit und vereinfachung
ihres lebens ermöglichen das nimmt
niemandem etwas weg danach fielen etwas
leichter und meine damen und herren wir
werden das strafrecht auf dem prüfstand
stellen und eines ist für mich heute
schon klar wenn sich frauen in einer
schwierigen lebenssituation
sachliche information auf dem internet
besorgen und so ist die
lebenswirklichkeit heute dann werden wir
sachliche informationen von ärztinnen
und ärzte nicht weiter unter strafe
stellen der b 219 er wird fallen meine
damen und herren ich
habe über freiheit gesprochen auch über
recht fehlt noch die einigkeit zur trias
unserer hymne die wird es hier im haus
nicht immer geben das ist auch gut so
das ist das haus von rede und gegenrede
und trotzdem würde ich mich sehr freuen
wenn auf dem geht der rechtspolitik
vielleicht hin und wieder auch mal
mehrheit zustande kommen die nah an
einigkeit reichen dafür möchte ich die
hand reichen und stehe für sachliche
debatten immer zur verfügung herzlichen
dank meine dankte
[Applaus]
der noch ziemlich neue bundesminister
dann wie die anderen ministerinnen und
ministern ist er jetzt fünf wochen im
amt hat einiges aus dem
koalitionsvertrag was im medizinbereich
justiz festgehalten ist und was wir
umsetzen würde ja genannt beispielsweise
das umstrittene werbeverbot für
schwangerschafts abbrüche soll fallen
aber soll auch änderungen im
familienrecht geben beispielsweise ein
neues gesetzliches modell für
lebensgemeinschaften nächste rednerin
jetzt andrea lindholz für die cdu csu
fraktion sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
herr bundesjustizminister sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen kollegen ich möchte ihnen
lieber herr buschmann zunächst einmal
ganz herzlich heute auch zur übernahme
ihres amtes gratulieren und ich wünsche
ihnen eine glückliche hand bei ihren
aufgaben
das was das ganze land seit wochen und
monaten umtreibt ist frage der pandemie
bewältigung und hier die frage der
impfpflicht und von ihnen als mit
zuständiger justizminister ist hier
heute nichts zu hören das ist ehrlich
gesagt enttäuschend auch wenn sie auf
ihre geringe redezeit verweisen andere
schwerpunktsetzungen die sie heute
vorgenommen haben wie zum beispiel die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft oder auch die
abschaffung der vorratsdatenspeicherung
das in schwerpunktsetzungen die kann ich
so nicht nachvollziehen und ich werde
auch viele ihrer inhalte so nicht teilen
und komme darauf noch später zurück
unser land befindet sich aber zunächst
einmal mitten in einer pandemie wir
haben heute die neue infektion erstmals
bei einer schallgrenze von 80.000 pro
tag erleben müssen die höchste zuvor
gemessene wert war hier 65.000 die
epidemische lage ist also noch nicht
vorbei wir sind mittendrin und sie
spielen auf zeit ihr haus ist mit
federführend zum beispiel verantwortlich
für die frage der einführung oder auch
nicht einführung des ob und wie es eines
registers fachleute aus dem
medizinischen ethischen und rechtlichen
bereich sagen wir ganz klar dass wir so
sowohl für diese krise als auch für
künftige krisen ein solches register
bräuchten und selbst der
datenschutzbeauftragte der
bundesregierung sagt dass es möglich ist
ihr hinweis darauf ist dass es jahre
dauern würde und das muss ich ehrlich
gesagt sagen genügt mir an dieser stelle
nicht und ich sehe auch nicht warum man
da nicht schneller sein kann gerade dann
wenn man doch vorhandene daten nutzen
kann und auf der anderen seite auch
genau weiß dass uns der korona virus
noch jahre beschäftigen wird kein wort
von ihnen dazu ebenfalls auf zeit spielt
die bundesregierung bei der impfpflicht
bundeskanzler scholz hat im november und
dezember eine orientierungs debatte für
die erste sitzungswoche angekündigt das
hat er nicht umgesetzt er hat sich für
die einführung einer impfpflicht zu märz
ausgesprochen sieht eher schlecht aus
immerhin haben wir heute in der
regierungsbefragung in etwa gehört was
er sich als abgeordneter vorstellen
stellt alle ab 18 und jetzt kommt die
rechtspolitik keine großen strukturen so
auf niedrigerem niveau auf niedrigerem
niveau ich nehme mal an herr buschmann
sie sind beim ersten punkt alle ab 18
zumindestens presse mäßig habe ich sie
da anders vernommen aber zumindest beim
zweiten punkt den großen strukturen
nachdem sie vorhin von der freiheit aber
auch der durchsetzung des rechtes
gesprochen haben sicher mit mir einer
meinung wenn man dieses instrumentarium
einführt dann müssen wir auch den
anspruch anspruch darauf haben es
durchzusetzen und da bin ich gespannt
welche vorschläge von ihrem haus kommen
fakt ist dass die bundesregierung in
dieser frage überhaupt keine
einheitliche linie hatte sie legt kein
gesetzentwurf vor stattdessen flüchtet
sie sich in gruppen anträge des
parlamentes und erklärt die frage zur
reinen gewissens frage vor dieser
debatte heute habe ich mich gefragt wo
ist eigentlich der unterschied zur
wehrpflicht die wir 2020 eingeführt
haben und wo ist eigentlich der
unterschied zu der teilung pflicht bei
pflegeberufen die sie mit dem
gesetzentwurf ganz zügig hier eingeführt
haben die antwort haben wir heute ja
vernommen herrschers der auffassung es
geht jetzt bei der erweiterten frage der
impfpflicht um den körper ging es um den
vorher nicht doch um den geht es immer
die richtung ändert sich ja aber die
richtung hat sich auch bei den
pflegeberufen geändert und es seien mehr
menschen betroffen sorry auch bei
dermaßen pflicht sind sehr viele
menschen betroffen tatsache ist die
antwort haben wir hier heute ganz klar
bekommt sie sind sich nicht einig sie
wissen nicht was sie machen sollen sie
haben keinen plan und deswegen flüchten
sie sich in gruppen anträge und erklären
dass zur eine gewissensfrage aber das
ist eine politische frage und sie sind
verdammt noch mal in der pflicht hier
ein plan vorzulegen
entscheidungsgrundlagen zu liefern zu
regieren und verantwortung zu übernehmen
tun sie das endlich
und wenn wir schon beim regieren sind
lieber herr buschmann waren sorgen sie
eigentlich endlich für die
rechtssicherheit für apotheker
apothekerinnen und apotheker wissen
nicht was sie mit gefälschten ausweisen
zeigen soll und wenn sie wenn sie diese
am ende noch anzeigen müssen sie auch
noch gefahr laufen dass ich selber ein
rechtliches problem bekommen wir haben
dazu ende november einen vorschlag
vorgelegt sie haben ihn abgelehnt und
bis jetzt keinen eigenen vorschlag
vorgelegt regierungshandeln sieht anders
aus da müssen sie schneller werden
stattdessen forcieren sie gesetze die
ich teilweise nicht nachvollziehen kann
bzw die eine nicht nachvollziehen kann
ich will ihnen drei nennen der kollege
krieges wird nachher noch auf weiteres
eingehen sie wollen das gesetz zur
wiederaufnahme einkassieren erstens
zweitens sie wollen die
vorratsdatenspeicherung abschaffen haben
sie heute erwähnt dritten sie wollen
eine wie sie es nennen historische
reformen im familienrecht auf den weg
bringen zu allen drei punkten sage ich
ihnen folgen des 21 ihre erste
amtshandlung soll es also sein das
gesetz zur wiederaufnahme überprüfen zu
lassen mit diesem gesetz das kurz vor
neuer verkündet wurde können in
absoluten extremen fällen von mord und
völkermord verfahren neu aufgerollt
werden wenn nachträgliche beweise
deutlich für die täterschaft eines zuvor
freigesprochenen sprechen und gerade für
hinterbliebene von opfern bei mord und
völkermord ist das ein signal der
gerechtigkeit
verfassungsexperten haben das gesetz
geprüft die spd hat es mit getragen der
bundespräsident hat es bundespräsident
hat es ausgefertigt und damit gerade als
verfassungsgemäß befunden und ihr erstes
und vorrangigstes anliegen ist es dass
möglicherweise wieder abzuschaffen dass
herr buschmann kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen die
vorratsdatenspeicherung ganz spannend
ihrer ausführungen vielleicht
unterhalten sie sich mal mit ermittlern
ermittlern im kampf gegen sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch für die ermittler in
diesem kampf während die
vorratsdatenspeicherung
eines der zentralen mittel im kampf
gegen sexuellen kindesmissbrauch
tausende fälle 1000 der fälle von
kindesmissbrauch könne nicht verfolgt
werden weil daten gelöscht sind im jahr
2017 betraf das allein 8400 hinweise
dieses instrument wollen sie abschaffen
ich frage sie ganz klar ist ihnen der
kampf gegen kindes braucht nicht wichtig
genug geht ihnen der datenschutz vor den
kampf gegen kindesmissbrauch
dann legen sie als verfassungsgemäß vor
da lasse ich mich jetzt nicht darauf ein
die angekündigte familienrechtsreform
lieber herr buschmann sie haben es
zitiert als die vermutlich größte
familienrechtliche reform der letzten
jahrzehnte und suggerieren der
bevölkerung hier gesamt mit der gesamten
ampelkoalition einen riesigen
handlungsbedarf ich sehe da als
fachanwältin für familienrecht weder
handlungsbedarf noch reformstau und
schon gar kein historischen
handlungsbedarf was sie wollen mit der
so genannten verantwortungsgemeinschaft
zumindest wenn man mal den fdp antrag
aus der letzten wahlperiode genau liest
dann soll das sowas sein die eheähnliche
privilegien aber ohne ähnliche bindungen
für zwei oder mehr menschen an zahl nach
oben unbegrenzt die sich jetzt irgend
einer weise verbunden fühlen und als
beispiele wird dann genannt damit man
besser auskünfte im krankheitsfall
bekommt oder damit im todesfallen
mietvertrag übernommen werden kann bis
hin zu themen wie unterhalten
zugewinnausgleichs ansprüche also
ersteres kann man jetzt schon regeln und
zweiteres sich mal für eine eheähnliche
bindung mit der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft von personen
die kein naheverhältnis haben kein
engels keinen kein ja ganz persönliches
verhältnis haben schon als sehr kritisch
an und in dem ganzen sehe ich schon
überhaupt gar keinen mehrwert für unsere
gesellschaft viel gravierender und das
ist ja das eigentliche ziel was sie
vorhaben sagen es ist doch deutlich man
muss ja nur im koalitionsvertrag lesen
ehe und familie taucht ja quasi gar
nicht vor sie schwächen mit einem
solchen institut ehe und familie und das
ist die keimzelle unserer gesellschaft
und ihre pläne dazu gehen noch weiter
ich nehme noch zwei weitere beispiele
zwei eltern im abstammung und mehr als
zwei eltern im abstammung und sorgerecht
wollen sie zu lassen ich sage ihnen ganz
ehrlich auch aus meiner praktischen
tätigkeit wenn eltern sich trennen es
reicht schon die streiterei bei 2 wir
brauchen nicht noch mehr personen die
sich beim sorge umgangsrecht oder auch
beim unterhalt streiten also das ganze
braucht wirklich kein mensch und zu
guter letzt lässt sich damit eines
festhalten ihre angekündigte historische
familienrechtsreform und ich empfehle
jedem mal den namen des programm der
ampel rhein zu gucken das ist keine
anpassung an den gesellschaftlichen
wandel das ist stattdessen so dass es
eine reine ideologisch motivierte
umerziehung unsere gesellschaft und das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
schlecht 1 das schwächt die institution
von ehe und familie und das steht nicht
im einklang mit unserer verfassung und
die union wird ein ganz genaues auge
draufhaben das kann ich ihnen
versprechen und am ende 1 comment sie
sich um die drängenden probleme in
unserem land ist aktuell die pandemie
und verschonen sie uns mit gesellschaft
gesellschaftspolitischen experimenten
vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau kollegin lindholz
andrea lindholz für die cdu/csu-fraktion
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
und ihr folgt jetzt ebenfalls als
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
allerdings für die sozialdemokraten dirk
wiese
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
bundesministerin der justiz rdr
buschmann ich glaube und das haben sie
ja gerade auch in ihrer rede ausgeführt
dass dieser ampel koalitionsvertrag
gerade in der rechtspolitik fortschritt
möglich macht und das glaube ich das ist
unser gemeinsames ziel diesen
fortschritt der sich in diesem
koalitionsvertrag findet auch gemeinsam
voranbringen und sie haben es
angesprochen und sie haben es auch
betont und dann auch an alle
demokratischen kräfte in diesem haus
gerichtet das auch gemeinsam jetzt hier
an einigen punkten vielleicht auch in
dieser legislaturperiode möglich zu
machen gemeinsam heißt aber nicht dass
man die möglicherweise ausgefallene in
diesem jahr politischen aschermittwochs
rede im bierzelt heute an dieser stelle
hier schon hält ich glaube das ist
dieser debatte sicherlich nicht
angemessen
und zeigt ehrlich das vielleicht auch
mit rückblick auf die letzte
legislaturperiode wo ich auch
bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht noch mal danke sagen will dass
es gut ist das vielleicht auch der
beschwerliche rucksack des rückschritts
der sicherlich bei einigen
rechtspolitischen themen da war uns
jetzt doch nicht mehr in die quere kommt
wir haben einiges vor in dieser
legislaturperiode wir haben und das
würde ich sagen aber auch einiges schon
vorangebracht wir haben eine nicht
einfache debatte zum
infektionsschutzgesetz gehabt das war
nicht gleich das war schwierig aber das
will ich auch noch mal sagen dieser
instrumentenkasten den wir als ampel im
infektionsschutzgesetz auf den weg
gebracht haben der war richtig der hat
gewirkt und es war eine richtige
entscheidung die wesentlichen
entscheidungen dieser pandemie in den
deutschen bundestag zurück zu holen und
dazu stehe ich auch das war eine gute
reform das war nicht einfach aber da
haben wir gezeigt dass die
zusammenarbeit hervorragend auch an dem
punkt funktioniert und ja wir werden uns
jetzt als deutscher bundestag der
debatte hier im deutschen bundestag auch
durch dann gruppenanträge in eine
orientierungs debatte und dem
fortlaufenden prozess stellen auf dem
weg eine impfpflicht hier im parlament
auch zu diskutieren da sind keine
einfachen fragen letztendlich die man
einfach von heute auf morgen so klären
kann und darum glaube ich ist es wichtig
und das haben wir auch gesagt hier in
dieser debatte gründlichkeit warten zu
lassen wir wollen eine gründliche
debatte wir wollen eine breite
gesellschaftliche diskussion hierüber
letztendlich auch möglich machen und ich
will das auch gerne an die kolleginnen
und kollegen der cdu csu berichten wir
laden sie ein sich konstruktiv in diese
erstellung der gruppenanträge sich
einzubringen das ist einige wichtige
gesellschaftliche diskussion ich war in
den letzten tagen etwas irritiert weil
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gemeinsam mit bundeskanzler oder scholz
war eine entscheidung der
ministerpräsidenten 16 zu null für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht also im gegensatz
zu ihnen waren ihre ministerpräsidenten
sehr klar an dieser stelle ich habe
gestern vernommen dass aus ihren reihen
ein eigener antrag im ersten ticker
morgens angekündigt worden ist er ist
mittags wieder eingefangen von friedrich
merz habe ich noch gar keine
stellungnahme genommen also kann ich nur
eins sagen sortieren sie sich kommen sie
in der opposition an aber bringen sie
sich in die gruppenanträge konstruktiv
ein alles andere ist hinter debatte
nicht würdig
und ich begrüße es ausdrücklich dass
dieser koalitionsvertrag gerade im
bereich der gesellschaftspolitik endlich
dazu kommt auch gerade mit der
angekündigten familienrechtsreform dass
endlich gesellschaftliche vielfalt in
diesem land anerkannt wird dass
gesellschaftliche vielfalt sich auch
endlich politisiert in den rechts
gesetzen wiederfindet und da haben wir
einiges auf der tagesordnung die mit
mutterschaft die reform des
transsexuellen gesetz ist die streichung
des 219 a aber auch die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft und ich finde
dass frau lindholz herablassend wie sie
darauf reagiert haben denn menschen
füreinander verantwortung übernehmen in
diesem land weil sie sie gleich nicht
vor den traualtar begeben das kann sein
weil sie vielleicht im alter weil sie
zusammenleben in einer senioren wg
gesellschaftliche verantwortung und auch
rechtliche verantwortung übernehmen bord
das so herablassend herabzuwürdigen wie
sie das machen wird der
gesellschaftlichen vielfalt in unserem
land nicht gerecht und das sage ich hier
auch sehr deutlich die heute in der
debatte ich halte es auch für wichtig
dass wir den pakt für den rechtsstaat
fortsetzen wir müssen die justiz weiter
stärken wenn wir hören diese woche das
fast 150000 ermittlungen pro jahr im
bereich hass und hetze auf uns zukommen
werden dann müssen wir die
justizbehörden letztendlich stärken wir
müssen auch die justiz digital
vorbereiten für die kommenden jahre ein
handlungsfähiger staat im bereich der
justiz ist entscheidend und da glaube
ich haben wir die richtigen schlüsse
gezogen mit dem pakt für den rechtsstaat
2 das was wir auf den weg gebracht haben
auch fortzusetzen und hier werden wir
auch ansetzt desweiteren nenne ich den
kollegen till steffen sehe als auch den
kollegen constantin coole auch im
bereich der planungs und
genehmigungsbeschluss übung haben wir
auch einiges voran zu bringen wir haben
das sehr konstruktiv in den
koalitionsverhandlungen bereits
diskutiert niedergeschrieben das war ein
sehr guter prozess aber auch hier werden
wir einiges voran bringen gerade was den
bereich der infrastruktur angeht hier
ist einiges möglich und das spielt
glaube ich auch die rechtspolitik eine
wichtige rolle das wird ebenso seien im
bereich des mieterschutzes auch hier
glaube ich ist einiges zu tun wir haben
einiges niedergeschrieben im
koalitionsvertrag um auch gewissen
sorgen und nöten gerade auch auf unsere
steigende miet auch gerecht zu werden
ich will auch deutlich sagen und dann
komme ich auch zum abschluss das auch
ein weiter wichtiger punkt im
koalitionsvertrag für uns sehr bedeutsam
ist und das ist etwas was glaube ich
auch gesellschaftlicher realität
rechnung trägt und das ist dass wir im
jahr 2022 endlich kinderrechte ins
grundgesetz schreiben muss
es kann aus meiner sicht nicht sein dass
kinderrechte im grundgesetz bisher immer
gescheitert sind dass es nicht voran
gegangen ist und auch hier der appell an
die kolleginnen und kollegen auch der
cdu csu springen sie hier über ihren
ihren schatten sehen sie es ein kinder
haben auch rechte in diesem land
kinderrechte im grundgesetz ist ein
wichtiges zeichen und das wollen wir
gemeinsam voranzubringen bringt vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
widmen so war das für die vielen spd
fraktion ja ein kinderrechte im
grundgesetz verankerte werden sollen
darauf hat sich die ampel koalition
verständigt koalitionsvertrag das wird
also kommen
jetzt thomas seitz für die afg fraktion
von der tribüne des präsidenten eine
justiz hatte muss premiere die frage
nach der freiheit stellen ganz besonders
wenn das ministerium einer
selbsternannten liberalen viel von
freiheit schwadronieren partei
untersteht die sich in wahrheit aber
längst durch und durch dem staat also
dem kältesten alten ungeheuer
verschrieben hat auch in einem
rechtsstaat geht die größte bedrohung
der freiheit der bürger immer vom staat
aus damit auch vom justizminister die
freiheits themen der letzten wochen
waren versammlungsfreiheit die
diskriminierung ungeimpfter und in
pflichten versammlungsfreiheit ist immer
minderheitenschutz denn die mehrheit
kann ihre anliegen auch ohne
versammlungsfreiheit artikulieren aber
wie ist es um die versammlungsfreiheit
bestellt wenn eine abgeordneten der
grünen wie saskia weishaupt auf twitter
ernsthaft den einsatz von schlagstöcken
und pfefferspray gegen friedliche
abweichler von der
öffentlichen doktrin fordert und warum
hat der justizminister sich nichts von
dieser äußerung distanziert und die
kolleginnen zum rücktritt vom mandat
aufgefordert die bürger
die aktuell ihren protest gegen im
pflichten kundtun können dies nicht ohne
angst vor repressalien tun in
baden-württemberg zum beispiel werden
allgemein verfügungen erlassen die über
wochen alle spaziergänge pauschal
verbieten und kriminalisieren ein blick
ins gesetz zeigt die problematik die
untersagung von versammlungen ist nach
beendigung der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite also seit november
2000 21 nachdem die fsg ausgeschlossen
diese generellen vorab verbote mit
androhung unmittelbaren zwangs sind auch
evident unverhältnismäßig vor allem aber
es offensichtlich dass friedliche
spaziergänger keine gefahr für unseren
rechtsstaat darstellen selbst wenn ein
verstoß gegen
versammlungsrecht vorliegt wäre die
auflösung eines friedlichen spaziergang
ist
unverhältnismäßig vor allem weil im
freien gerade keine relevante
ansteckungsgefahr besteht
ich sage es ganz deutlich
diese spaziergänger verteidigen den
rechtsstaat und ihre kriminalisierung
ist unrecht diese bürger verteidigen den
rechtsstaat gegen eine regierung der das
grundgesetz die rote linie für jedes
staatliche handeln nach ausdrücklicher
ansage des kanzlers egal ist und gegen
einen justizminister der vor allem
herumlavieren weil er eigentlich gerne
eine impfpflicht einführen würde aber du
vor den konsequenzen des bruchs eines
zentralen wahlversprechens
zurückschreckt solange nicht zwang die
zwangs geimpft werden kann ist das
mittel der wahl die diskriminierung
aller die sich nicht oder eben kein
zweites drittes viertes oder wievielten
mal impfen lassen wollen die gestern
erlassenen faschistoiden maßnahmen der
präsidentin mit der abgeordnetenrechte
in einer seit langem
gekannten weise beschränkt werden sind
ein herr abgeordneter ist möchte sie
bitten bei unserer parlamentarischen
sprache zu bleiben und ich glaube dass
sie nicht so geschichtsvergessen sind
etwas was für heute an maßnahmen machen
mit einer sehr dunklen zeit dieses
landes zu vergleichen
sprach von faschistoiden habe nichts
dagegen aber ich als abgeordnete habe es
trotzdem relativ einfach im vergleich zu
den normalen menschen die
gesellschaftlich geächtet und vom
sozialen leben ausgeschlossen werden im
vergleich zu jungen menschen deren
studium oder berufsausbildung faktisch
unmöglich gemacht werden im vergleich zu
arbeitnehmern im gesundheits- oder
pflegesektor die trotz des bestehenden
personalmangels durch die verabschiedete
besondere impfpflicht aktuell in scharen
aus ihren beruf gedrängt werden schon
vor wochen hat der bundeskanzler olaf
scholz nach dem grundgesetz der träger
der wichtigen kompetenz sich für eine
impfpflicht für alle als kanzler
festgelegt und ihre einführung für ende
februar anfang märz angekündigt so
einfach wie gedacht läuft es aber nicht
denn so offensichtlich ist dieser
abschluss ich bitte um nachsicht ich
habe ja keine uhr denn schon
offensichtlich ist aber ihre regelfall
ist jetzt abgelaufen das sag ich ihnen
gerade kommen sie jetzt bitte zum
schluss ein letzten satz ja
so offensichtlich ist es dass eine
impfpflicht unverhältnismäßig und
verfassungswidrig ist scheitert die
impfpflicht scheitert olaf scholz aber
konnte ihnen pflicht scheitern der
justizminister jedenfalls dann wenn er
sein amt als vertreter der freiheit
verstärken und nicht als
erfüllungsgehilfe zeit zwar dass es der
rechtspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
und er spricht von der tribüne die
allgemeinverfügung hier was die regeln
und bundesweite anbelangt sind geändert
worden von der bundestagspräsidentin und
unter anderem dürfen im plenarsaal nur
personen sein die 2g plus regeln
erfüllen auf der tribüne dann solche die
zumindest einen schnelltest vorweisen
können nächster redner helge limburg für
die grünen
der einzige beitrag zur rechtspolitik in
ihrer rede erkannt habe war der dass wir
eine parallele aufgezeigt habe zwischen
einem gerichtssaal und dem plenarsaal
nämlich dass jede noch so abseitige
meinung irgendwie vorgetragen werden
darf aber das gleichzeitig diejenigen
die versuchen mangelnde inhaltliche
substanz durch lautstärke und frechheit
zu ersetzen eben am ende nicht recht
bekommen er sei
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zu den dingen die unser
solidarisches zusammenleben sichern der
justizminister hat es gleich eingangs
gesagt gehört natürlich auch das recht
es gehört zum fundament unserer
freiheitlichen demokratie eine
demokratie ohne rechtsstaat ist wenig
wert beides gehört zusammen in
öffentlichen debatten ist immer wieder
mal von der vollen härte des
rechtsstaates die rede die ist
sicherlich auch manchmal notwendig aber
der begriff des rechtsstaates entstand
ursprünglich in abgrenzung zu absoluten
monarchie und ähnlichen regierungsformen
also der rechtsstaat das recht begrenzt
gerade die macht des staates in die
rechte der bürgerinnen und bürger
einzugreifen deshalb wird es auch ein
zeichen der stärke des rechtsstaates
sein wenn diese ampel koalition endlich
die vom bundesverfassungsgericht
angemahnte
überwachungs gesamtrechnung vornehmen
wird der justizminister kollege emmerich
und andere haben es auch schon
angesprochen die zahlreichen angriffe
die die sicherheitsgesetze den
vergangenen jahren ermöglicht haben
werden dann endlich auf das unbedingt
erforderliche maß begrenzt werden und
die anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung
online tools wird dann in der tat auch
formalrechtlich der vergangenheit
angehören nicht nur tatsächlich und
durch grundrecht schonende verfahren wie
quick freeze ersetzt werden und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist stärkt auf
den rechtsstaat wenn wir das strafrecht
von ballast befreien und auch seinen
kern begrenzen im strafrecht stehen in
der regel der täter und die tat im
mittelpunkt trotz verbesserungen den
letzten jahren gibt es aber vor allem im
bereich der unterstützung der opfer
weiterhin verbesserungsbedarf diese
ampel koalition wird lücken im opfer
entschädigungsrecht endlich schließen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich gerne
den kollegen pascal kober ganz herzlich
zu seiner neuen aufgabe als beauftragter
für opferschutz gratulieren ich wünsche
ihnen eine gute antreten
besonders schlimm ist ist das haben sie
ja zurecht angesprochen wenn kinder
opfer von straftaten werden diese
koalition wird den kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch verstärken durch
verfahren die quick freeze durch eine
verbesserte zusammenarbeit der behörden
und vor allem aber auch dadurch dass wir
sicherstellen werden dass die justiz an
allen stellen kindgerecht und sensibel
reagiert liebe kollegen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
schuld die nie vergeht lautet der titel
des lesenswerten buches von coach
schwimmen dem früheren leiter der
zentralstelle zur verfolgung von
ns-verbrechen und weil diese schuld nie
vergeht es laufen ja auch noch ns
verbrechen weil diese schuld nie vergeht
werden wir im einvernehmen mit allen
landes justizministerinnen und -minister
ministern die zentralstelle zu einer
dokumentationsstelle umwandeln die afg
und ihr umfeld haben ja ausdrücklich
erklärt stolz sein zu wollen auf die
wehrmacht wir und da weiß ich die union
und auch die linke mit eingeschlossen
sind stolz auf die arbeit der
juristinnen und juristen die seit über
70 jahren es sich zur aufgabe gemacht
haben die ns verbrechen juristisch
zurannten verbrechen zur rechenschaft zu
ziehen auch die juristen wollen wir
stolz einige kolleginnen und kollegen
das recht als fundament oder
freiheitlichen demokratie ist jedoch
ebenso wenig statisch wie es unsere
gesellschaft ist dort wo gesetz und
verordnung nicht mehr angemessen sind
nicht mehr den realitäten des
menschlichen zusammenlebens entsprechen
liebe kollegin lindholz müssen wir sie
anpassen und das gilt auch wenn sie es
nicht wahrhaben wollen insbesondere im
familienrecht es hat in den letzten
jahren ja bereits bedeutende änderung
gegeben frau linke lindholz etwa die
einführung der ehe für alle also für
alle die wollen natürlich aber wichtige
dinge sind eben leider liegen geblieben
die diese ampel koalition und
entschlossen angehen wird wer ist in der
tat die verantwortungsgemeinschaft es
ist doch letztlich im interesse von uns
allen im interesse der gesellschaft wenn
menschen erklären wir wollen für
einander einstehen wir wollen
verantwortung füreinander nehmen wir
wollen das auch rechtlich festlegen es
ist auch im interesse der gesellschaft
und ist stärkt familien es stärkt
familien auch und gerade im sinne des
grundgesetzes wenn wir auch
patchworkfamilien rechtlich besser
absichern rechtlich besser stellen und
das
und das beste ist doch all das nimmt
wirklich niemandem etwas merkt herr
buschmann ich bin dankbar dass sie das
betont haben frau lindholz wovor haben
sie denn eigentlich angst wovor haben
sie denn eigentlich an
sie haben die ausführung nicht an einer
stelle darlegen können wer eigentlich
wem eigentlich schaden zugefügt werden
könnte dadurch dass wir als koalition
als fortschritts koalition die
möglichkeiten im familienrecht erweitern
wollen wir werden ebenfalls das
abstimmungs recht reformieren was für
die rechtliche vaterschaft geht muss
auch für die rechtliche mutterschaft
gelten wer bei geburt verheiratet ist
der muss rechtlich als eltern gelten sie
wissen dass da einfach verantworten
bundesverfassungsgericht liegt gute
recht politik wartet nicht immer auf
kreis- movies in der vergangenheit viel
zu oft der fall war gute rechtspolitik
handelt
auch präsidentin liebe kollegin kollegen
unser rechtsstaat ist keine rein
nationale angelegenheit und deshalb ist
ein zentrales anliegen dieser koalition
die europäische zusammenarbeit und
justiziellen bereich zu stärken die euro
just und europäische staatsanwaltschaft
stärker zu unterstützen wir wollen den
whistleblower schutz
umsetzen und damit endlich eine
eu-richtlinie die eigentlich sie schon
hätten umgesetzt haben müssen weil hier
tatsächlich in deutsches recht umsetzen
wir werden die kollektiven rechtsschutz
ausbauen menschen müssen sich leichter
als bislang zusammenschließen können um
gemeinsam ihre individuellen rechte
geltend zu machen
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen alles auf
neustart in der rechtspolitik war der
titel einer veranstaltung am deutschen
anwalts waren gestern war ja viele von
uns auch gemeinsam bahn und ich finde er
ist sehr passend für die vorhaben in der
rechtspolitik wie sie sehen gibt es in
diesem bereich sehr sehr viel zu tun ich
freue mich auf die debatten im
rechtsausschuss und auch auf die
rechtspolitischen debatten im plenum
vielen dank
hamburg der rechtspolitische sprecher
von bündnis 90 die grünen und die
debatten in den ausschüssen ja das wird
dann so weit sein wenn die ersten
vorhaben dann auch als gesetzentwürfe
vorliegen und dann das parlament sich
damit befasst die fraktionsvorsitzende
der linksfraktion ist jetzt am
rednerpult am ihrer moore mit all i see
geht der frau präsidentin kolleginnen
und kollegen der minister buschmann sie
haben sich unter anderem vorgenommen das
strafrecht auf seine wirksamkeit zu
überprüfen und systematisch zu
überarbeiten das ist sehr sinnvoll
denn einige paragraphen die sind
wirklich nicht mehr zeitgemäß
aber hier braucht es taten statt bloße
ankündigung wir sehen aber leider zum
beispiel bei der versprochenen cannabis
legalisierung dass es an eben diesen
taten fehlt wenn sie liegt auf eis die
begründung die begründung ist die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie hat jetzt
vorrang aber gerade wegen der korona
pandemie wäre es doch jetzt besonders
wichtig die behörden von unnötigen
verfahren und ermittlungen zu befreien
wie der verfolgung von
cannabiskonsumenten darum handeln sich
hier
die justiz und strafverfolgungsbehörden
die würden außerdem erheblich entlastet
durch die streichung eines zutiefst
ungerechten und absolut überflüssigen
straftatbestandes nämlich dem fahren
ohne fahrschein in öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel
und weil das immer wieder vermischt wird
in der debatte noch einmal zur
klarstellung selbstverständlich soll das
fahren ohne fahrschein nicht erlaubt
werden das ist ja quatsch ich darf erst
einmal will auch nicht auf dem parkplatz
von meinem nachbarn paten aber wenn ich
das trotzdem mache dann mache ich mich
damit nicht strafbar aktuell ist es so
dass menschen allen ernstes im gefängnis
landen wenn sie sich kein verein und
danach die geldstrafe leisten können und
das sowohl vollkommen unverhältnismäßig
kolleginnen und kollegen
und außerdem ist das auch zutiefst
sozial ungerecht gerecht denn wer landet
denn im gefängnis die die sich einfach
kein ticket gekauft haben weil sie
irgendwie das vergessen haben uns
einfach nicht wollten natürlich nicht im
gefängnis landet ein obdachloser ein
anderer armer mensch der einfach kein
geld hatte für einen fahrschein die
können sich dann nämlich es rechtlich
die geldstrafe leisten und dann landen
sie eben per ersatzfreiheitsstrafe im
knast klassenjustiz kann man das nennen
und hier möchte ich sagen für uns linke
ist ganz klar wir müssen armut bekämpfen
statt arme menschen zu kriminalisieren
politik
und diese klassenjustiz übrigens nicht
nur ungerecht sie es auch teuer das war
das portal fragt den start de gemeinsam
mit dem zdf magazin royal recherchiert
jeder tag denn jemand für fahren ohne
fahrschein im gefängnis sitzt der kostet
den steuerzahler bis zu 188 euro darum
beenden sie endlich diesen irrsinn
der nächste punkt sie wollen die justiz
gemeinsam mit den ländern ertüchtigen
dass das denken aber ein paar schicke
digitalisierungsprojekte allein die
werden das problem der heillos
überlasteten justiz und
ermittlungsbehörden nicht lösen den
ländern fehlen schlicht personal und ja
für personal sind die länder zuständig
aber auch hier kann der bund wichtige
weichen stellen um die länder zu
entlasten zum beispiel beim thema
geldwäsche wir wissen hier kommen die
behörden schon lange nicht mehr
hinterher darum ist deutschland
inzwischen ein regelrechtes geldwäsche
paradies für kriminelle aller art
geworden die geld welche geschieht dabei
zum größten teil über
immobiliengeschäfte und um das zu
verhindern brauchen wir endlich ein
immobilien register damit es eben nicht
mehr geht das briefkastenfirmen ende
keiner mehr weiß wer da eigentlich
dahinter steckt dass die ihr geld in
immobilien geschäften reinwaschen können
außerdem muss es verboten werden es um
million in bar bezahlt werden können die
spd war in der vergangenheit immer
dagegen stattdessen auf
strafverschärfung gesetzt was aber
erkennbar keine entlastung für die
behörden bringt ja wie denn auch
kolleginnen und kollegen hier ist
dringend ein kurswechsel überfällig
und abschließend also wir finden es
wirklich sehr gut dass die § 19a endlich
aus dem strafgesetzbuch streichen wollen
dass ersten und ärzten verbietet über
schwangerschaftsabbrüche zu informieren
aber bitte setzen sie das auch wirklich
um vielen dank
haben ihrer mohammed ali war dass die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
die aber auch ordentliches mitglied im
rechtsausschuss ist für die linke und
deswegen auch unter anderem hier das
wort ergriffen hat ja in
kriminalisierung von schwarzfahren das
hat sie gefordert das ist durchaus ein
projekt was ich hier am koalitionen auch
hier auf die agenda geschrieben hat
nämlich das strafrecht zu entschlacken
und da könnte beispielsweise auch das
schwarzfahren
anders geregelt werden
sie haben nicht nur heute sondern mit
ihrem wirken in den ersten wochen der
amtszeit eines unmissverständlich
deutlich gemacht die zeit für
veränderungen ist gekommen in der
ampelkoalition
werden bürgerrechte wieder groß
geschrieben wir stellen nicht alle
bürgerinnen und bürger unter
generalverdacht verschärften nicht
einfach blind sondern wir schauen sehr
genau hin welche maßnahmen überhaupt
effektiv und tatsächlich notwendig sind
und wir bleiben grundrechts schont
deshalb erklären wir zb der
verfassungswidrigen anlasslosen
vorratsdatenspeicherung
auch eine endgültige absage stattdessen
schaffen wir mit dem quick freeze
verfahren ein wirksames instrument frau
kollegin windholz gerade auch im kampf
gegen den sexuellen missbrauch von
kindern sieht schön hier haben überhaupt
nichts zu wege gebracht wir kümmern uns
sodann das worüber sie sich hier
mokieren das nennt sich zeitgemäße
familienpolitik ich weiß nicht wie oft
ich in der vergangenen wahlperiode
gestanden habe und gerade im
familienrecht in ewigen stillstand
kritisiert habe mit dem ende der
regierungszeit der union gelingt es nun
endlich die fesseln der
rückwärtsgewandtheit abzulegen liebe
kollegen von der union gehen sie mal
raus und machen sie die augen auf sie
klammern sich an gestern die
gesellschaft ist längst weiter auf
freunde über neben dem alter
verantwortung füreinander kümmern sich
und wollen füreinander einstehen unter
anderem ihnen hilft das neue
rechtsinstitut der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft und niemanden
wird etwas genommen
kinder deren vestische eben hinein
geworden geboren und beide frauen
möchten mit einverständnis des vaters
rechtlich eine eltern stellung
übernehmen das kind wird von vornherein
in rechtssichere verhältnisse geboren wo
ist das problem
peter überleben immer mehr
erziehungsverantwortung für ihre kinder
und kinder brauchen beide eltern das
muss unser familien vielleicht auch
spiegeln ich freue mich deshalb
wahnsinnig auf die größte
familienrechtsreform der letzten
jahrzehnte die der minister angekündigt
hat denn sie wird vielen menschen
tatsächlich in ihrer lebensrealität
helfen
aber auch sonst tun wir was lange
überfällig ist ich bin unfassbar dankbar
dass der unsägliche § 29 10 a
strafgesetzbuch nun ersatzlos gestrichen
wird und dieses der minister dieses
projekt ja auch schon angegangen sind
insofern seien sie bei der linksfraktion
unbesorgt es ist unerträglich dass sich
ärzte die sachlich über
schwangerschaftsabbrüche
informieren auch im netz im jahr 2022
immer noch dem risiko einer
strafrechtlichen verfolgung ausgesetzt
sehen frauen in solchen
in situationen brauchen die möglichkeit
sich umfassend informieren zu können
also liebe oppositionsfraktionen weniger
nach hinten blicken mehr fortschritt
wagen die stagnation ist vorbei wir wird
jetzt frischer wind
ihren dank belegen
[Musik]
für die cdu csu fraktion erhält jetzt
das wort der kollege dr günter krings
in meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
zunächst mal eine herzliche glückwünsche
an den bundesjustizminister sie haben
eines der schönsten ressorts der
bundesregierung anvertraut einem klugen
rechtspolitiker aber die pointe mit
haben sie gerechnet auch ein kluger kopf
in einem wichtigen das war garantiert
eben noch nicht zwingend eine kluge
politik ich freue mich in dem sinne auch
kritisch konstruktive debatten in den
nächsten jahren und die ersten links
signale der ampel zeigen das ist ja
schon heute mehr anlass für kritik gibt
als selbst meine gar nicht so kleine
rede zeit zulässt der titel oder im
titel des koalitionsvertrags ist die
rede von fortschritt freiheit
gerechtigkeit in der rechtspolitik der
ampel sehen wir hier bislang aber weder
fortschritt noch gerechtigkeit sondern
vor allem den versuch eines
gesellschaftlichen umbaus aufgrund eines
aus meiner sicht falschen
freiheitsverständnis
zunächst wir sehen einen leichtfertigen
umgang mit unserem grund aus grundgesetz
aufgrund auch unausgegorener
änderungsvorschläge in der titel 3
absatz 3 soll der begriff rasse ersetzt
werden das mag ein gut gemeintes
vorhaben seien aber wir wissen das
gegenteil von gut gemeint ist häufig
eben gut und die implizite nicht gewollt
aber implizit unterstellung die mütter
und väter unseres grundgesetzes oder
andere autoren aktueller rechtstexte
hätten einem rassistischen denken
angehangen ist er jedenfalls absurd dann
schlagen sie die aufnahme von
kinderrechten ins grundgesetz vor und
ihr schwebt ihnen offenbar jetzt in der
ampel etwas ganz anderes vor als der
vorschlag auf den sich die große
koalition in der letzten wahlperiode ja
bereits geeinigt hatte den sonst hätten
sie den ja zustimmen können auch von fdp
und co der damalige vorschlag hatte eben
den charme dass er elternrechte nicht
verkürzt denn wir meinen dass in aller
regel kinder interessen am besten mit
und nicht gegen ihre eltern durchgesetzt
werden
die ampel regierung plant hingegen einen
angriff auf das erziehungsrecht der
eltern dass bundeskanzler olaf scholz
den sehnlichen wunsch hat die zieht ihre
lufthoheit über den kinderbetten zu
erringen wissen wir ja schon seit 2002
das heute bei diesem eindringen des
staates in die familie aber auch wie
liberale mitmachen das ist für mich in
der tat eine doch noch in erkenntnis
meine damen und herren was mich an
dieser debatte aber am meisten ärgert
dass sie sich den schutz von kindern in
der gesellschaft richtigerweise auf die
fahnen schreiben aber dann einen
eigentlichen problemen der kinder vorbei
marschieren nicht im grundgesetz gibt es
etwas für die kinder zu tun sondern vor
allem im gesetzesrecht jahr für jahr
gibt es tausende fälle von
kinderpornografie frau kollegin linz hat
darauf hingewiesen die eben nicht
aufgeklärt werden können weil
verbindungsdaten nicht gespeichert
worden 2020 alleine
2600 fälle
den kindern die drohen opfer solcher
grässlicher straftaten zu werden den
helfen eben keine kinderrechte im
grundgesetz sondern nur konsequente
strafgesetzen erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der fdp-fraktion
selbstverständlich politik berlin
obwohl ich schon lange redezeit haben
aber eine frage von mir machen wollte
vielen dank frau präsidentin lieber
kollege chris da sie noch einmal auf die
vorratsdatenspeicherung zu sprechen
kommen frage ich sie einfach da sie ja
nun als union 16 jahre lang die
regierung gestellt haben warum haben sie
es denn nicht geschafft in diesen 16
jahren eine verfassungsgemäße und
verfassungsfeste version einer
vorratsdatenspeicherung ins gesetz platz
zu schreiben und sind sie nicht auch der
meinung dass den kindern und den
kinderrechten vielmehr geholfen ist dass
die fortschritts koalition jetzt einen
verfassungsgemäßen vorschlag mit quick
freeze auf den weg bringt als ständig
die von ihnen 16 jahre praktiziert eine
lösung vorschlägt und ins gesetzblatt
schreibt die kurz darauf von allen
gerichten von einfachen gerichten bis
zum verfassungsgericht und dem
europäischen gerichtshof hin als
verfassungswidrig erachtet wird was ist
denn da die bessere bildung
[Musik]
vielen dank frau präsident und vielen
dank herr kollege für diese frage die
man noch mal gelegenheit gibt einiges
etwas ausführlicher darzustellen und ich
sage mal zunächst es gibt hier noch
anhängige verfahren europarechtlich
verfassungsrechtlich insofern würde ich
immer sehr vorsichtig sein mit einer
voreiligkeit dass wir generell hier
keine verfassungskonforme lösung auf
dieser basis finden erste punkt zweiter
punkt ist quick freeze muss man sich so
vorstellen dass wir heute abend nach
hause kommen schauen dass sie ihre tief
kultur besonders scharf und kühl
unterkühlen wenn aber nichts drin ist
dann bringt ihn das gar nichts wenn wir
uns auch nicht sagt davon dass es bei
den daten genauso wenn sie keine daten
haben weil sie erst auf den anlass
warten und dann aber ermitteln müssen
bringt im krieg fließt leider gar nichts
das mag verfassungskonform sein aber das
vollkommen unwirksam so nicht sagen
in den 16 jahren haben wir ja vier jahre
auch gemeinsam regiert mit einer
fdp-justizministerin
deutlich kürzer hier als letzte unions
justizminister so und wir haben damals
auch gemeinsam hier an lösungen
gearbeitet auch kompromisse gefunden und
ich sage ihnen einen ganz konkreten
punkt wer aber nicht anlasslos ist
sondern anlassbezogen sich
anlassbezogenen anlasslos ist was man
machen können sie nach ansicht der meist
verfassungsrechtler möglich ist
jedenfalls mal die ip-adressen länger
speicherbar zu machen und dann länger
zuordenbar zu machen damit wir uns die
ganze menge dieser kinderpornografischen
grauslichen fälle schon aufklären aber
das geht nicht
anlassbezogene datenspeicherung sollen
sie brauchen auch da die anlasslose ich
kann wenn sie auf dem weg gehen haben
wir vielleicht eine chance und zu
verständigen aber bitte seien sie hier
offen auch dafür dass wir manche dinge
auch anlasslos speichern müssen sonst
helfen wir den kindern diesen
furchtbaren opfern in den opfern dieser
furchtbaren verbrechen nicht lasst uns
etwas gemeinsam für die sache erreichen
dass man herzliche bitte
nicht sagen auch außerhalb des themas
von datenspeicherung wir haben nur
wahlprogramm ganz konkrete vorschläge
und forderungen drin etwa wenn es um
konsequente strafgesetze geht auch die
elektronische fußfessel stärker auch für
die täter von sexualdelikten nutzbar zu
machen den richtern dieses instrument zu
geben wir haben gesagt wer kinder
missbraucht hat darf ich nur für ein
paar jahre ins strafregister eingetragen
werden er muss lebenslang im
strafregister eingetragen werden selbst
wenn er vom ein ende des landes ans
andere ende um zieht er darf nie mehr an
kindern herankommen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und da gibt es im ampel
vertrag leider keine entsprechenden
passagen und ich haben eben gesagt mit
einer nur noch anlassbezogen
datenspeicherung kommen wir an die täter
eben nicht heran aber damit nicht genug
sie fordert er sogar ein pauschales
recht auf anonymität und jetzt kommt im
internet wie in der realen welt also die
frage ist jetzt wann wir denn die kfz
kennzeichen deutschland abschaffen das
wäre ja dann entsprechend auch in der
logik dieses vorschlages unausgegoren
ist noch das freundlichste weil sich
dazu leider sagen muss
aber der von mir kritisierte
leichtfertige umgang mit dem bund jetzt
der macht eben auch bei änderungen des
einfachen gesetzes rechts nicht halt als
erste tat der ampel in der rechtspolitik
wurde angekündigt vom justizminister
abschaffung des werbeverbots § 209 10
aber schwangerschaftsabbrüchen hier
wurden noch mal betont ersatzlose
streichung dieses paragraphen ist der
plan ernsthaft ist dass die erste
priorität in diesen zeiten wir würden
hier stattdessen einige andere maßnahmen
und der rechtspolitik einfallen
umsetzung der triage entscheidung des
verfassungsgerichts oder einen
regierungsentwurf wohlgemerkt
regierungsentwurf über eine impfpflicht
über umfang ob umfang einer impfpflicht
denn was sich zurzeit machen ist als in
gruppen anträge zu schieben um zu
kalkulieren dass es hier offenbar keine
mehrheit in der regierungsmehrheit gibt
leichtfertig und gefährlich an der
abschaffung des werbeverbots ist aber
dass damit ein wirklich sehr fein
austariertes system
eingegriffen wird in dem der schutz des
ungeborenen kindes immer mit dem
freiheit schutz der mutter zusammen
gedacht werden muss
das ist vorgegeben durch den ersten
artikel unserer verfassung und wurde in
einer schwierigen politischen
konsensfindung entwickelt und ich sage
das in großer ernsthaftigkeit aber ruhe
einer politik die diesen konsens
aufkündigt und werbung im zusammenhang
mit der tötung menschlichen lebens
zulässt können wir christdemokraten und
christsoziale unsere hand nicht reichen
und wir haben doch nach schwierigen
debatten in der großen koalition 2009 10
hier eine lösung gefunden dass
informationen eben deutlich erleichtert
werden der jetzt mehr will jetzt
informationen der will eben werbung und
das ist etwas anderes den wir nicht
beitreten können
und für die ampel ist das ja anscheinend
auch nur der erste schritt wenn ich rein
schauer eine kommission zur
reproduktiven selbst reproduktiven
selbstbestimmung soll offenbar prüfen ob
der schwangerschaftsabbruch aus dem
strafgesetzbuch gänzlich herausgenommen
werden soll
damit würde das gesamtgefüge des
lebensschutzes eben endgültig zerstört
und ich finde ohne not an
gesellschaftlicher streit eröffnet und
diesen streit haben wir in deutschland
anders als in vielen unserer
nachbarländer
jahrzehntelang glücklicherweise
vermeiden können ich bitte sie daher
wirklich inständig betreiben sie nicht
mutwillig hier die spaltung unseres
landes
meine damen und herren die
schwerpunktsetzung der ampel im bereich
des strafrechts ist aber insgesamt
fatale antworten auf die probleme
aktuellen probleme mit telegramm etwa
mit der kleinkriminalität oder im
bereich von zuhälterei und prostitution
fehlen eine einzige strafe schaffung
enthält der koalitionsvertrag
die ampel koalition möchte teile des
tierschutz rechts in das strafrecht
überführen und das strafmaß hier erhöhen
dafür mag es gute gründe geben auch wenn
das strafmaß ihren keineswegs zu gering
ist wie manche denken aber bitte passen
sie auf dass unser strafrecht nicht am
ende angriffe auf tiere strenger
bestraft als angriffe auf menschen
und mit priorität das stichwort fiel
auch bereits in der innen- und der
rechts debatte wollen sie eine
überwachungs gesamtrechnung auf den weg
bringen
heißt das etwa ganz konkreten das muss
er dann mal konkret gemacht werden wenn
dann vizekanzler habeck mehr
kontrollbefugnisse gegenüber
umweltsündern durchsetzt muss dann
innenministerin feser zum ausgleich eine
vorschrift zur terrorbekämpfung
streichen und die gesamtrechnung dann
nicht aus der balance zu bringen ich
hoffe doch wohl nein egal was sie sich
hieraus denken meine sorge ist am ende
bleibt das ausdruck eines misstrauens
gegenüber unseren ermittlungsbehörden
wir haben wir als union unseren behörden
und gerichten zunächst einmal mit
respekt und vertrauen begegnen wollen
meine damen und herren
mit einer grundsätzlichen bemerkung
schließen ich weiß aus eigener
parlamentarische erfahrung nach
landläufiger auslegung ist das
justizministeriums für die freiheit
zuständig und das innenministerium für
die sicherheit als jemand der seit fast
zwei jahrzehnten innen und rechtspolitik
im bundestag betreibt empfehle ich der
neuen regierung diesem staatspolitischen
kurzschluss nicht zu fall die
rechtspolitik und eben auch natürlich an
justizminister sind im freiheits wie dem
sicherheitsversprechen unseres staates
gleichermaßen verpflichtet freiheit ist
das höchste ziel des rechtsstaates aber
freiheit bleibt eben nackte theorie oder
vielleicht ein luxusgut für wenige
wenn sie nicht auf der stabilen basis
der sicherheit steht wenn nicht sicher
sein kann dass er eine reise überlebt
wird lieber zuhause bahn
jederzeit damit rechnen muss dass man
ihnen sein hab und gut abnimmt wird
vielleicht gar kein eigentum erwerben
deshalb brauchen wir eine konsequente
verbrechensbekämpfung mit zeitgemäßen
ermittlungsmethoden und wie ein
verantwortlicher stelle in der innen und
rechtspolitik steht darf sich dem nicht
verweigern denn wenn die sicherheit
nicht ernst nimmt verspielt auch die
freiheit deshalb bleibt die
rechtspolitik der union eine politik der
freiheit auf dem festen fundament für
sicherheit
im hintergrund war dass der
rechtspolitische sprecher der cdu csu
fraktion ja sehr viel gutes hatte den
koalitionsvertrag
neben ressort rechte nicht gefunden wie
der fortschritt noch gerechtigkeit so
finger schon seine rede an und hat mich
auch nochmal an der
vorratsdatenspeicherung
abgearbeitet die will der
bundesjustizministerin endgültig aus dem
grundgesetz streichen derzeit liegt die
vorratsdatenspeicherung die auf eis ist
aber selbst noch im gesetz und quick
freeze davon war häufiger die rede war
immer wieder als grundgesetz oder
alternativ im gespräch
[Musik]
zunächst möchte ich ihnen herr
bundesminister buschmann herzlich
gratulieren ich wünsche ihnen eine
erfolgreiche amtszeit und freue mich auf
eine vertrauensvolle und konstruktive
zusammenarbeit seitens der spd
bundestagsfraktion
ich freue mich heute meine erste rede in
diesem hohen hause gerade zu diesem
wichtigen thema zu halten und die
rechtspolitische vorhaben unseres
koalitionsvertrages besprechen und
beleuchten zu dürfen denn unsere
rechtspolitik wird geprägt sein von
fortschrittlichen denkens von tatendrang
und von aufbruch
gemeinsam mit unseren kolleginnen und
kollegen von den grünen und der fdp
werden wir problemfelder anpacken in dem
das recht heute wirklich der gelebten
wirklichkeit in unserem lande
hinterherhinkt und dabei muss natürlich
wie heute auch schon oft erwähnt auf das
familienrecht und die
familienrechtsreform eingegangen werden
insbesondere zeigt aber auch die debatte
und die hier ausgetauschten ansichten
doch warum die progressiven kräfte in
diesem land auch die bundestagswahl
gewonnen haben und eine reaktion auf
den gesellschaftlichen wandel in unserem
land ist und land gibt denn wir müssen
die vielfältigen lebensmodelle des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts auch in
unserer rechtssystem mit einbeziehen und
verankern wir wollen getrennt erziehende
in der rechtlichen situation verbessern
die mit mutterschaft ermöglichen und die
heute häufig genannte
verantwortungsgemeinschaft
einführen und umsetzen und auch
die abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a
spielt damit rein denn frauenärztinnen
muss es ermöglicht werden hier umfassend
aufzuklären und darum geht es doch es
geht nicht um eine werbung es geht um
eine aufklärung und es ist tatsächlich
ein anliegen wo schon die generation
meiner mutter für gekämpft hat von daher
ist es wirklich zeit dass das auch
schnell
wir werden stärker gegen diskriminierung
vorgehen und hierzu schutzlücken auch im
allgemeinen gleichbehandlungsgesetz
schließen und außerdem ist es ein
anliegen der rechtspolitik gerade sich
auch mit konkreten fragen beschäftigen
die die breite masse der bevölkerung
beschäftigt sehr wichtig für uns als spd
ist es dabei alle menschen in unserem
land im blick zu haben und ihnen ein
gutes leben zu ermöglichen
deswegen sind wir auch sehr sehr stark
daran interessiert den mieterschutz zu
verstärken und uns hier insbesondere
auch für ein set einzusetzen denn wohnen
darf kein luxusgut sein
auch in diesem bereich kann die
umsetzungen der hinweisgeber richtlinie
gefasst werden denn diejenigen müssen
geschützt geschützt werden die
strukturelle missstände und straftaten
taten aufdecken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden die bürgerrechte
stärken es wurde angesprochen dazu
gehört es dass immer wieder
ausbalanciert wird wie das verhältnis
zwischen sicherheit und freiheit ist
dass beides nicht gegeneinander
ausgespielt wird dort sondern das eben
auch die ja vom verfassungsgericht
geforderte überwachungs gesamtrechnung
nun auch tatsächlich in angriff genommen
wird es ist nicht nur eine idee der
neuen koalition sondern tatsächlich auch
eine forderung unseres höchsten
gerichtes gewesen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
als junge richterin ist es mir aber auch
besonders wichtig die funktionsfähigkeit
unseres rechtsstaates in den blick zu
nehmen und in diesem rechtsstaat eben
entsprechend zu investieren das wollen
wir mit einer fortführung für den pakt
für den rechtsstaat machen und diesen
werden wir das auch wiederum dringend
notwendig ist um einen digital corp für
die justiz ergänzen denn wer recht hat
muss in unserem land auch recht bekommen
können ich kann ihnen versichern dass
bei den gerichten sehr hart daran
gearbeitet wird und auf hochtouren die
vielen vielen akten bearbeitet werden
der beschleunigungsgrundsatz ernst
genommen wird aber man muss das auch
eben mit mehr personal unterlegen in der
richterschaft in der staatsanwaltschaft
bei den geschäftsstellen und im it
personal denn wir brauchen eine digitale
justiz die richter suchen in
gürteltieren während der rest des landes
steuerung oft benutzt es kann keine
realität im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert
liebe kollegen die bandbreite der
angesprochenen themen lässt den aufbruch
vor dem wir stehen er an wir haben uns
viel vorgenommen aber wir haben noch
größeren tatendrang packen wir es an
bringen wir in dem neuen progressiven
bündnis unseren rechtsstaat voran ich
freue mich darauf und auf die
konstruktiven diskussion in diesem haus
vielen lieben dank
diese reichweite war das hier mit ihrer
ersten rede für die spd fraktion sitzt
sie im bundestag
und
ist direkt gewählte abgeordnete aus dem
wahlkreis brandenburg an der havel
potsdam mittelmark und
vor ihrem einzug in den bundestag war
sie richterin fabian jacobi jetzt für
die afg den satz geschrieben wem es an
respekt vor dem parlament fehlt dem
fehlt es offenbar auch an respekt vor
dem volk ich habe heute das zweifelhafte
vergnügen zum ersten absehbar nicht zum
letzten mal als abgeordneter an rede an
das parlament aber nicht im parlament zu
halten da sich schon früher hier oben
sagt war noch meine freie entscheidung
zeichen der solidarität mit den menschen
die sie durch ihre maßnahmen ausgrenzen
entrechten und erniedrigen nunmehr ist
mir die entscheidung abgenommen nicht da
als abgeordneter das parlament nicht
mehr betreten die abgeordneten des
bundestages vertreten das ganze volk
jedenfalls dem anspruch der verfassung
nach durch die spaltung des parlaments
seiner demonstrativ sichtbar gemachte
teilung in reine und unreine
negieren sie den anspruch der trasse und
an das parlament
hier fehlt es den bundestag selbst
jedenfalls seiner agierenden mehrheit an
respekt vor dem parlament und damit dem
sinnspruch des herrn ministers zufolge
an respekt vor dem volk ein übles omen
für die neue zeit welche diese neue
regierung ja einzuleiten gedenkt was ist
nun für die kommende neue zeit aus dem
ressort des herrn ministers zu erwarten
hat der blick in den vertrag der sie
geschlossen haben zeigt vieles das wir
als opposition sehr kritisch begleiten
werden einiges weniger über das man
immerhin reden könnte und dann sind da
die dinge die auf keinen fall realität
werden dürfen mehrheiten kommen und
gehen und gesetze die sie beschließen
können später wenn wir vor den ruinen
stehen die diese regierung hinter lassen
wird auch wieder geändert werden
wirklich gefährlich wird es wenn sie
anfangen die verfassung im sinne ihrer
ideologie zu verändern zwei pläne zur
änderung des grundgesetzes die schon in
der vergangenen periode im
rechtsausschuss behandelt wurden
glücklicherweise nicht zum abschluss kam
nun aber wiederum verfolgt werden das
ist zum einen das hineinschreiben von
sogenannten kinderrechten in das
grundgesetz
dass ausgerechnet jetzt nachdem der
urheber des drohenden spruches von der
staatlichen luft hat über den
kinderbetten zum kanzler geworden ist
dabei etwas anderes herauskommen könnte
als ein einfallstor für staatliche
übergriffig kite gegenüber den familien
das kann man getrost ausschließen das
zweite ist der plan aus dem grundgesetz
das verbot der rassendiskriminierung zu
streichen ersetzt werden soll das
bekanntlich durch eine vorschrift über
diskriminierung aus rassistischen
gründen wenn man nun weiß dass nach die
ideologie der jetzt herrschenden
parteien rassismus etwas ist das sich
ausschließlich gegen menschen mit
bestimmten hautfarben richten kann die
menschen mit anderen hautfarben aber nie
dann ist damit klar worauf das
hinausläuft
menschenrechte nach hautfarbe auch das
ist mit uns nicht zu machen
das werden dann übrigens die punkte sein
an denen die cdu die ja nach den
aussagen mancher den weg der
rehabilitierung gehen und wieder eine
bürgerliche partei werden möchte ihre
prüfsteine finden wird gegen afd und
cdu/csu ist eine änderung des
grundgesetzes jedenfalls nicht möglich
wir werden sehen wie die andere
oppositionspartei sich verhält vielen
dank
[Applaus]
ich möchte feststellen dass sich dieses
parlament so flexibel zeigt dass sie
ihre rede sehr klar und deutlich halten
konnten und in einer form in der sie
nicht alle anderen abgeordneten die hier
sind gefährden obwohl das vermeidbar
wäre nein ich liebe keine des zum
letzten mal wieder
als nächstes erhält das wort für bündnis
90 die grünen die abgeordnete canan
bayram
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
16 jahre
strafverschärfungen und aushöhlung der
beschuldigtenrechte haben ein ende damit
ist jetzt schluss jetzt ist zeit für
evidenzbasierte
kriminalpolitik und rechtsstaatlichkeit
und darüber bin ich ehrlich gesagt sehr
froh hier muss man das wieder schön in
ihren interviews die sie jetzt über den
jahreswechsel gegeben haben deutlich
gemacht haben denn unsere verfassung die
macht klar strafrecht soll und muss
ultima ratio sein und wir werden in so
weit so wie sie es befürchtet haben frau
lindholz liberalisieren wir werden
legalisieren wir werden in den
entkriminalisieren und ehrlich gesagt
freue ich mich auch schon darauf
denn es kann doch nicht sein dass
menschen ins gefängnis kommt weil sie
sich kein u bahn ticket leisten können
frau mohammed ali hat es hier gesagt und
freut sich ebenfalls darauf herr
buschmann dass wir das zusammen ändern
wollen das ist ungerecht damit machen
wir schluss ebenso ungerecht ist es
menschen dafür zu bestrafen dass die
lebensmittel aus dem meer retten nein
das sind für mich helden die willig
feiern und nicht bestrafen und klar ist
für uns auch dass endlich die
strafbarkeit der sogenannten werbung für
den schwangerschaftsabbruch nach
§ 209 10 a des strafgesetzbuches zu
streichen ist die information darüber
dass abbrüche in einer praxis angeboten
werden ist keine werbung sondern teil
der medizinischen versorgung und die
wollen wir gewährleistet haben meine
damen und herren der völlig absurden
praxis der strafrechtlichen verfolgung
von ärztinnen werden wir ein ende setzen
wir konzentrieren uns vielmehr auf die
wirklich erforderliche bekämpfung von
kriminalität sei es bei der
geldwäschebekämpfung mit der einziehung
von illegalen vermögenswerten oder die
bekämpfung der organisierten
kriminalität durch höhere transparenz
insbesondere im bereich der
immobilienwirtschaft das ist das wofür
wir uns einsetzen wollen meine damen und
herren
und wollen organisierte kriminalität
immer häufiger grenzüberschreitend
stattfindet verbessern wir verbessern
wir auch die justizielle zusammenarbeit
in der europäischen union mit einer
starken europäischen
staatsanwaltschaft und einer klaren
gesetzeslage zur ausstellung des
europäischen haftbefehls meine damen und
herren für die effektive strafverfolgung
geben wir den behörden die finanziellen
und technischen möglichkeiten und mittel
an die hand indem wir den takt für den
rechtsstaat verlängern die kollegin hat
das vorhin auch schon gesagt und um
einen digitalen pakt für die justiz
erweitern dazu wollen wir die
strafprozesse reformieren wir wollen sie
effizienter machen und gleichzeitig die
stärkung der beschuldigtenrechte durch
die auszeichnung von vernehmung der
hauptverhandlung stärken ja und ich kann
hier aus meinem vorgänger als direkt
gewählten abgeordneten in friedrichshain
kreuzberg einen gruß schicken lieber
hans christian ströbele will stehen kurz
davor
wir geben bald das hand frei das ist das
wofür wir hier auch stehen wir wollen
dass menschen nicht mehr dafür
kriminalisiert werden denn dieses verbot
macht gar keinen sinn und wir wollen
stattdessen dafür sorgen dass nur
erwachsene an diesen wertvollen stoff
heran kommen und dieser dann auch in
einer qualität geliefert wird die
niemandem schadet regulierung und
aufklärung statt repression das ist das
was diese koalition sich vorgenommen hat
meine damen und herren und weil das in
meinem wahlkreis friedrichshain
kreuzberg und prenzlauer berg ost viele
menschen beschäftigt die angst sie haben
es mehrfach gesagt sie wollen sicherheit
herr coole die angst der menschen vor
verdrängung aus ihren kiezen die angst
der menschen ihre wohnung zu verlieren
die dürfen wir nicht opfern für eine
freiheit von schutz für eine freiheit
von gesetzen die menschen schützen dass
sie in ihren wohnungen bleiben können
nein wir brauchen einen mieten stopp wir
brauchen mietrechtliche bestimmungen die
die menschen in ihren wohnungen halten
wir brauchen ein kommunales
vorkaufsrecht damit der staat die
mieterinnen schützen kann und ich biete
ihnen natürlich mein wunderschönes
gesetz zum schutz der gewerbe
mieterinnen an denn auch die gewerbe
mieterinnen sind bedroht von verdrängung
brauchen ihren schutz lassen sie uns
freiheit solidarität
gemeinsam denken in diesem sinne freue
ich mich auf die zusammenarbeit mit
ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
vielen dank frau kollegin beider
als nächstes erhält das wort für seine
erste rede im bundestag der kollege
margit karaahmet ohne für die spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen hetze und
drohungen im internet sind noch immer
als kalt gegenwärtig auch wenn die
vorangegangene justizministerin in den
letzten jahren viele verbesserungen
bewirken konnte
insbesondere das gesetz zur bekämpfung
des rechtsextremismus und der
hasskriminalität war ein wirklich großer
wurf diesen weg wollen wir weitergehen
aber auch das möchte ich an dieser
stelle klar stellen die anonymität im
netz werden wir hierbei nicht antasten
die regierungskoalition hat sich
vorgenommen mit einem gesetz gegen
digitale gewalt rechtliche hürden für
opfer zb bei auskunft rechten weiter
abzubauen wir wollen zudem bessere
beratungsangebote aufsetzen und es
braucht rechtliche rahmenbedingungen für
elektronische wege der
anzeigenerstattung und auch richterliche
richterlich angeordnete account sperren
müssen möglich sein es ist gut dass wir
diese punkte im koalitionsvertrag
festgelegt haben und es ist im sinne
aller betroffenen dass wir hier zügig
und mutig vorangehen
wir stehen aber auch vor
herausforderungen bei denen die gesetze
alleine nicht weiter helfen die
radikalisierung innerhalb der querdenker
und
impfgegner szene im virtuellen raum
macht dies ganz tagesaktuell deutlich
nach recherche der tagesschau gab es
alleine im november und dezember letzten
jahres über
250 morddrohungen in öffentlich
zugänglichen gruppen des messengers
telegramm man muss sich also
leicht oder man kann sich leicht
ausmalen welche dimension an vergifteten
gewaltfantasien sich in den
geschlossenen gruppen verbergen und oft
geht es ja nicht nur um rechtliche
grundlagen sondern um recht durchsetzt
und elegant zum beispiel sitzt in dubai
und ignoriert konsequent gesetzliche
vorgaben deutschlands
wir brauchen also neue ansätze um dieser
gefährlichen schieflage herr zu werden
auch auf europäischer ebene und im
gespräch zb mit app store anbietern
bei
gewalt im netz geht es um straftaten die
vor allem von männern gegenüber frauen
begangen werden die vorangegangene
bundesregierung hat hier längst
überfällige schritte unternommen und
beispielsweise das heimliche
fotografieren unter den rock oder in die
bluse unter strafe gestellt auch die
neufassung des paragrafen 201a stgb war
eine wichtige anpassung aber aber die
gesetzeslage wird der schwere viele
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen vor
allem im bereich der sexuellen
intimsphäre noch immer nicht gerecht die
strafandrohung steht hier in keinem
verhältnis zu den folgen der taten
insbesondere in der digitalen
öffentlichkeit von internet und sozialen
medien richten solche übergriffe in die
intimsphäre einen unfassbar großen
psychischen und sozialen schaden bei den
opfern an in vielen fällen ist der
schaden vergleichbar mit sexualdelikten
und um insbesondere die sexuelle
intimsphäre besser zu schützen benötigen
wir auch hier entsprechende anpassung
des strafrechts hierfür werbe ich um
unterstützung vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
vorher hat hier einige punkte genannt
die er sich vorgenommen hat ein neuer
abgeordneter für die spd-fraktion budget
karaahmetoglu von beruf ist er anwalt
eine rednerin haben wir noch zum ressort
justiz auch mit ihrer ersten rede kamen
im deckel wird es seien für die
sozialdemokraten
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen parteien sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir haben in den
letzten minuten viel über aufbruch und
viel darüber gehört dass wir unser land
nun auch rechtspolitisch endlich im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ankommen
lassen daher möchte ich meine zeit
darauf verwenden um über unseren mut
zusprechen unseren mut gesellschaftliche
ungerechtigkeiten nicht nur zu benennen
sondern sie auch zu überwinden und den
mut darüber sich den kundinnen und
feinden der demokratie entschlossen in
den weg zu stellen
hier
wir haben diesen gut und das möchte ich
ihnen an zwei ganz konkreten
rechtspolitischen vorhaben in der
nächsten legislatur aufzeigen wenn wir
bei gesellschaftliche ungerechtigkeiten
sprechen dann müssen wir auch über die
strukturelle benachteiligung von frauen
in unserer gesellschaft reden darüber
dass sie in vielen fällen immer noch
nicht selbst über ihre körper bestimmen
können und ihnen das gesetz in einer der
schwersten situation ihres lebens im
wege steht und auf grund der ausführung
der opposition ist es glaube ich
notwendig dass sich hier noch mal
umfassend darauf eingehe jedes jahr
werden in deutschland bis zu 100.000
schwangerschaftsabbrüche vorgenommen das
bedeutet bis zu 100000 situation in den
frauen eine schwere entscheidung treffen
und auf der suche sind nach ärztinnen
und ärzte indien zur seite stehen in dem
bundesland in dem ich wohne in bayern
gibt es laut bundesärztekammer einige
städte und sogar regionen in denen
schwangerschaftsabbrüche nicht mehr
möglich sind in niederbayern der
oberpfalz und auch in größeren städten
wie augsburg regensburg würzburg oder
ingolstadt gibt es offiziell keine
einzige klinik die schwangerschafts
abbrüche anbietet in einem freistaat mit
mehr als 13 millionen einwohner innen
übernimmt ein arzt knapp ein drittel
aller schwangerschafts abbrüche
das ist vollkommen absurd
und jetzt welche mich natürlich fragen
wie können dass sein woran liegt das das
liegt daran dass wir eine regelung in
unserem strafgesetzbuch haben die ist so
genannten lebensschützer innen und
radikalen abtreibungsgegnerinnen
ermöglicht regelrecht jagd auf ärztin zu
machen die abbrüche vor ort durchführen
seines drohbriefe oder eben anzeigen
weil sie es allein dadurch werbung
machen könnten indem sie den abbruch in
ihrem leistungsprofil aufhören die folge
ist eben doch werter kollege das immer
eine ärztin sich aus diesem bereich
zurückziehen sich beschränken auf die
durchführung von abtreibungen auf sich
bei ihren eigenen patienten und diese
bieten sie dann eben nicht mehr generell
an all das erschwert also nicht nur die
arbeit von ärztinnen sondern geht
insbesondere auf die kosten von uns
frauen und das ist ein unhaltbarer
zustand
er hat sind wir mutig wir sind mutig wir
favorisieren schwangerschafts abbrüche
wir stärken das reproduktive
selbstbestimmungsrecht von frauen wir
streichen 219 aus dem strafgesetzbuch
endlich
und wissen sie was noch gültig ist wir
halten unser rechtes auge furchtlos
geöffnet wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern von menschen die mit
fackeln vor unseren haustüren stehen und
wir lassen uns auch nicht einschüchtern
von menschen die in telegramm kanälen
zum mord an politiker in den aufrufen
wir lassen uns nicht einschüchtern
sondern gesehen hören und handeln
entsprechend
und auch wenn das einige zu vergessen
scheinen soziale plattform und der
digitale raum sind keine rechtsfreien
räume mit dem digitalen
gewaltschutzgesetz mein kollege hat es
angesprochen werden wir genau dem
entgegenwirken wir werden denen die hass
und hetze im netz verbreiten zeigen zu
was ein rechtsstaat fähig ist und
diesen und den haben wir er zieht sich
durch alle unsere rechtspolitische
vorhaben in dieser legislatur und das
ist eine handschrift die sie in den
nächsten jahren von uns und insbesondere
von der spd erwarten dürfen ich kann nur
sagen ich freue mich drauf vielen dank
für die spd fraktion eine der abordnung
design die über diesen vorhaben dann
weckt unter anderem im rechtsausschuss
beraten wird ihm bereitet ja und sie war
auch die letzte rednerin zu diesem
ressort drei tage lang wird über die
politik der ampel koalition beraten
heute ist der erste tag zum auftakt
stand ja gegen 13 uhr war das werden sie
sich jetzt dazu geschaltet haben olaf
scholz erst mal als bundeskanzler in
einer regierungsbefragung den
abgeordneten rede und antwort dann haben
wir schon das ressort innen und heimat
mit dem bundesinnenministerium nancy
faeser hier gehabt jedes gleisen marco
buschmann dem newsdienst investor
bereich recht